Panut: In Sumatra, the
Leuser Ecosystem is
one of the largest and most
intact tropical rainforests
left in Southeast Asia.
It is the only place in
the world where you have
Sumatran tigers,
Sumatran rhinos,
Sumatran elephants and orangutan
living together in the same
place at the same time.
Unfortunately,
the Leuser Ecosystem
the forest is shrinking.
( applause )
For the last 15 years
I have been dedicating my
life to saving orangutans.
These orangutans are living
in the Leuser Ecosystem
on the island of
Sumatra, Indonesia.
So, the forest of orangutan
is really, really precious.
And not just orangutans
that depends on this forest
for their survival
but humans depend on this
forest for many, many reasons.
And I would say that the
orangutan is actually
the guardian of the forest
because they actually keep
regenerating, you know.
They keep planting trees.
They are the best
gardener of the forest.
And that means actually they are
the symbol of our fight
against global warming.
Unfortunately,
the Leuser Ecosystem,
the forests in Sumatra and
also in Borneo are shrinking
because of the bad planning.
Even the Leuser Ecosystem
is not even recognized
in the government's
special plan.
80% of the orangutan
habitat has been gone,
mainly for plantation.
And not just orangutan
that is suffering
because they are losing habitat
but also many other
animals become victims
of human-wildlife conflict.
And for orangutan,
being stranded is a problem.
It's a big, big trouble for them
because they cannot go anywhere.
They cannot find food
and a picture like
this showing you
like, you cannot go anywhere,
and you face starvation.
And you can imagine that like,
with this kind of situation,
where orangutan just have
no trees
left to go back to the forest
and people can get access to
actually shoot the mother
and get the baby for pet-trade.
This is a big male orangutan,
kept there for 20 years.
You can see the small door there
when he was actually taken,
when he was very small.
Now he is lucky because
he is now in safety.
And this gentleman,
look at that handsome.
And but-- unfortunately
this guy is actually
really, really in trouble
because
he is living in a very
small forest patch
and we try to bring
him into safety.
So, we come to the
plantation area
and we check every tiny forest
patch left in the plantation
that is surrounded by
palm oil plantation.
And sometimes we found
these things, that is sad.
Orangutan cannot survive
in the plantation.
And we have to rescue.
When we rescue orangutan
on top of the trees
top of the canopy like
this, like that--
You can see that it's
very risky, dangerous.
But we have to do it anyway
otherwise they are in trouble,
being shot, you know,
or captured
or even die of starvation.
And then we have to get the
mother, check their health
while the orangutan
is still actually asleep
because of the anesthetic
because we actually
tranquilize the orangutan.
And not just young orangutan
but also male orangutan
that we have to rescue.
And this massive
animal, you know
we have to really
carry into safety.
Sometimes we have to go
find a very best place
crossing the river, and we
sometimes have to cross
you know, peat swamp, and
then we have to move them into
safety in the Leuser forest.
And, this is like a happy moment
when I see actually
orangutan being released.
It's a freedom. This is
something that we want to do,
we want to achieve.
This is our final goal.
Keep forest as forest.
We want to secure the habitat
so we chop down illegal
palm oil trees.
And then we plant them
with forest trees.
And that is actually my son
planting trees with me.
And then, this is just showing
you how we plant trees
for growing forest
from beginning
and we actually look
at it from the top.
And for five years,
actually we got this.
So, which is really,
really promising
and I believe that this is
like bringing you a new hope
that we can do something,
we can help our nature.
And not only that, but
animals coming back.
And then this actually
this is also becoming playground
for many, many animals.
So not only that but also many,
many people, local people
coming to learn and join us to
actually help with the project
and this being--
this bring a good
momentum for local people
that we can still
save our forest.
So, it's never
too late to save our nature
so, you can do your own,
your own part, and I believe
you can contribute
in your own way.
So, please join me and save our
rainforest and orangutans.
Thank you.
( applause )